okay hi everyone we're going to talk
about public relations today I'm Sharon
I actually worked at Y Combinator and I
work on our continuity team which is the
team that does growth stage investing so
Series B Series C investing and also
trying to create programs and give
advice to founders as they enter into a
different phase of their startup right
after they've built a great product they
have to then go build a company and make
it a really great company so that's what
we try to do we'll try to help with on
the continuity team before I was at YC I
was the chief marketing officer at green
dot which is a fin tech company makes
prepaid debit cards and checking
accounts that don't let you overdraft so
really targeting an under banked
population as public company and I got
there by being acquired I was at looped
which is the startups was actually Sam
Altman startup so I worked with Sam
there for two years and before that I
was at PR agencies so I was at two
different PR agencies probably had a
total of 20 clients over that period of
time ranging from startups to big
companies like Intel so I've done a lot
of kind of on-the-ground PR work and
also have thought about it from a
strategic level and also get to talk to
founders from YC every day about sort or
about PR and marketing so that's why I'm
here talking to you and and the testing
is even though it's going to be about PR
you're not going to escape the standard
YC advice which is while PR might be
interesting is something that that could
help in some ways for your business your
number one job as a founder is to focus
on your product and that's you're not
going to escape that so even if PR is
interesting that's the key the key goal
and I bring it up because without
product innovation PR it's not going to
be an option for you this startup curve
is the one that Paul Graham drew way
back probably looks familiar but the
fact is is you could get some great
article written about your product but
if you get people in there and they
they're disenchanted by it or not
impressed they're not going to come back
so you're not going to have something
that's ongoing that you can really
depend on it's not a customer
acquisition channel so if press
motivates you if being on the cover of
Wired is something that you think would
be cool that's cool
we'll have that motivate you and create
a product that pres cannot ignore right
that's how you get great PR results is
creating an amazing product so that's
the first thing you can do now that said
you notice your first job but there are
something I am going to actually give
you some some tangible tools and steps
and you can take to to start a PR
program my first tip though for
early-stage founders is don't go and
hire a PR agency or a PR person I really
believe for early stage founders that
founder led PR is simply the only way to
go for a lot of reasons but mainly I
think it's actually special you know
reporters like hearing from founders
that's the end folks person for them so
there's not someone going in between
there's someone who they genuinely can
learn from and gather information from
knocking right on the door
I guess usually this forms an email but
you're getting exposure to someone who
could actually be a spokesperson for me
for you so it's it's special and it's
something that's kind of unique to the
vibe that you can pull off when you're
at an early stage and the other side is
you have something to offer you
you may pitch some reporter today and
that news might not fit into their
coverage for the day or for the week but
in a month something really relevant to
that area could happen and they'll call
you because you're a subject-matter
expert you know your domain you know
your business and that helps them craft
a story that helps them give background
your story so it's I would kind of think
about it is not kind of a switch you can
flip from a PR perspective but really
you're trying to establish a
relationship and trying to just get the
ball rolling getting your company name
out there your product out there and
just establishing yourself as a credible
spokesperson so this is the next
question I always get when I when I say
that for a speech so I just really want
to take a second to just knock down
these myths and I even sent out some
questions to a lot of folks in start-up
school and I got some of these questions
so questions back about PR agencies and
so first reason why people might think
that they really really need a PR person
to come in right away and help them so
they might help define the business and
be jargon eyes it and yes communicate
folks can be really good at that but
you're kind of depriving yourself of a
process it's going to be really useful
beyond media relations being able to
define your business in a clear and
concise way is going to pay back in
every aspect of your business when
you're talking to a potential investor
when you're talking to a potential
partner when you're trying to hire your
first few engineers you need to be able
to clearly pitch them on what makes your
business special and why they should
listen to you so don't deprive yourself
of that process they come up with story
angles right so they're paying attention
to the news well you're a better
spokesperson to found review if you
follow the news you need to understand
where your business fits in the news I'm
not saying you should spend five hours a
day is pouring over every news site but
you should have a good pulse you know a
couple times a day check in and and look
at the stories that are relevant to your
business and just more broadly
understand where your business fits in
the world the third reason and the most
common reason I get is that they know
the reporters they hold these
relationships they're the ones that can
make it happen and I'll tell you there's
no no credible reporter would ever write
a story because they like what to drinks
with someone they'll write a story
because it's a good story right so story
always Trump's a relationship so focus
on that focus on a product that has a
story focus on a product it has traction
which is a story and that's what can
pull that cuz that's what can start
creating those relationships for you
it's not a magic kind of key you can
turn and they field media enquiries
right so they'll be able to respond to
press in a timely manner
it's a pretty high-class problem to have
if you're getting tons of meeting
parades that you can bearly that you're
drowning in them you probably have some
pretty good product traction and maybe
you know you're having a blazing success
and then you have permission to hire a
strategic communications partner who can
help help you through that
and lastly they're good at sending
invoices not to minimize that to PR
agency or PR professional but this is
it's it's essentially over a head of a
lot of ways because there's no
guaranteed results it could be a you
know an agency can come in they don't
know your business they have to learn
your
business so probably about a month out
and then they start pitching it might be
two weeks out three weeks out two months
before you even get a story in the news
and it's even then that's not guaranteed
to drive specific business school
because it's not a engaged measureable
customer acquisition tactic so get to a
place where you have a really good team
that can build that great product your
engineering team your product team
yourself and that's what you should kind
of focus on so hopefully I've convinced
you but I do think that there are some
simple things the founders can do to
chip away at the PR goals themselves and
eventually once you are successful you
should hire a PR firm they're cool I
used to work one all right so five steps
and these are really based on my
experience but I'm also weaving in some
common YC advice in the batches received
when they come through YC specifically
this one step one who are you so this is
this long list is the checklist of a
whiteboarding session at Y Combinator so
companies that come through YC will get
a great presentation by cat Michalek
who's a partner oh I see and then
they'll meet with their group partners
and go through each of these questions
and this is something that I implore you
to take time and think about so invite a
family member or friend in someone who's
not steeped in your world who can
actually kind of give you some real
advice on whether or not your
description is jargon or make sense to
the common man in any town USA but most
importantly what does your company do
we'll talk about that more and being
able to describe your customers so how
does your product live through your
customer through the lens of their
customer people like stories about
people so this is a great one for PR
what problem what problem are you
solving and how are you measuring how
you're growing and how are you growing
who are your competitors and why are you
better than your competitors what are
your plans for next year and I think the
one of the more important ones for PR as
well is why you why did you start this
company why are you uniquely qualified
to bring this product to the world and
that can range from stories of something
you overcame that caused you to
for this field and to conquer this
technology and this innovation or it
could be that you came from a company
that that has done this kind of and
you're you broke off and are doing it
better so the founder stories are really
great to establish early on because
sometimes we can forget that about
ourselves right that we bring something
special to the table so to dive a little
bit deeper on the what does your company
do the biggest advice is to lead with
the what not the why and what I mean by
that is even though we've established
that you're all cool founders and that
you're uniquely qualified to start your
business that's kind of a long story to
get all at once so instead of some like
big paragraph where I have to really try
to navigate understand what your company
actually is it's a lot easier for you to
say to me well ride electric is Boeing
for electric airplanes I get that you're
making them they're electric tell me
more right I want to lean in I want to
hear more actual company from the last
batch of YC by the way Dropbox it
synchronizes your files across your and
your team's computers that's easy to
understand it might seem silly now but
this is actually their description on
their YC application years and years ago
so the overall summary here is make it
conversational which means no jargon no
preamble just get right to it and above
all they get kids ice so step 2 we're
going to define your goals in your
audience and this one it's kind of a
first principles type process because PR
actually isn't a goal so saying my goal
is to get a lot of press it actually
isn't your goal if you really really
step back you're actually striving
toward a business school so you want to
maybe recruit the best talent you want
to finance your growth drive trial and
strategic partners you have things that
you're trying to do with your business
so you want to ask yourself this is the
business thing
I want to do is there a strategic is
there an audience that I can maybe
influence to help me get there press
aren't the
and they have they have readers though
so press might be the window to your
audience so talking getting a story
placed or working with press to get some
story place could be a way to reach this
priority audience so if your priority or
your business goal is to finance growth
your audience might be investors right
so that's kind of how you need to break
it down and um really try to prioritize
it cuz if everything's a priority then
nothing's a priority so really try to
focus in if your goal of press is
investors it's actually going to
influence the reporters that you try to
talk to and the publications that you
try to get in and so you want to ask
yourself and the other obviously piece
of YC advice that I'm sure already all
doing is building your product and
talking to customers and repeat repeat
repeat so if you're talking your
customers anyway maybe ask them what
they read and that's a good way to kind
of get to what outlets you might want to
consider thinking to get in so which
brings us to our next step step 3
reading which might seem common sense
but so if you already read the news
probably you already do um it's just
maybe putting a little bit more
structure around how you look at the
news so if you read a really compelling
article that you feel like hits some of
the notes that you as a founder
represent or that your product speaks to
then look who wrote it right that person
maybe would be interested in a story
about you in your company so the big
tips here as you kind of prepare for
this is also I get a lot of questions
from technical founders on like how to
bring efficiency to this and so the real
answer is there's not like tons of
efficiency in this this is about
relationship building it's there's not
something that can automate it but here
are some tools a Google spreadsheet so
that's the biggest tool I think that
people might use for PR so just kind of
organizing your thoughts you read a
great article grab the link note who
wrote it and write a little bit to
yourself about what what was relevant
and how you think your story might play
with that same reporter given their
interests and given their coverage area
and think about what angle might
interest them which we'll talk a little
bit more about
and then think about connections to them
so we talked about how PR agencies
aren't vital for relationships but it is
nice to get a warm introduction to a
reporter so if you see that that
reporter has written about someone you
know maybe it's an or an investor might
know them so maybe another founder has
appeared in the stories we might reach
out to that founder draft an email up
for them and say hey would you mind
introducing me to this reporter I think
they might be interested in my product
right so that's that's the connection
spam column on angle I think I kind of
wanted to specifically point out
business press because for an
early-stage startup it's not always a
relevant target for people because I'm
going to do an audience question out who
would what would you guess is the most
common topic in covered in business
outlets funding Manny yeah for starters
most is this you have to have something
that ties to like market-moving
Commerce the economy so funding is a
good example for where startup might get
into this another example where startup
might be able to get a story in the
business press would be if you're really
getting a lot of traction and and like
upsetting the stream of someone else's
business so you're taking advertising
dollars away from Facebook or you have
an app that can hail a car and it's
maybe disrupting a taxi business like
these are kind of things that will get
you into this press even before you get
really big because you're showing signs
of disruption you're showing signs that
there's something to look at here so I
wanted to kind of cover that one because
it's a common question the other element
so as you start reaching out to
reporters and I'll give you some
examples of pitches that have actually
gone out and just remind just a reminder
that everything you say is is on the
record the reporter's job is to to get
the story and they just are kind of
gathering all the information you give
them so unless you I mean if you share
metrics of your business they may write
about them so it's a common if I city
gives YC companies before demo day to
write when they're really excited to
share everything about their business
and they share all their metrics and
they might be surprised in the next day
when
an article talks about the metrics of
their business so just it might seem
like common sense advice but it's really
easy to forget in the moment so just
keep in mind
be open be transparent share honestly
but if you don't want your metrics in
the news don't share them okay so what
to say
and time to outreach so you're going to
start reaching out you have already
looked at your kind of year ahead and
thought about what news you might have
maybe it's your actual company launch
maybe it's a product launch maybe you
have fundraising maybe you got some
investment might hit some milestones
maybe you have some statistics that are
cool these are all examples of company
fueled news the other type of news is
trend based news so how your company
fits in a bigger trend so things like
like a roundup of a new finance apps and
maybe you're going to be one of those
apps that's names I usually say that
they the journals will usually only name
three like they're not going to spend
their day like listing an exhaustive
list of all the 15 20 30 apps that exist
so to the degree that you have engaged
with the reporter in a meaningful way it
may be they don't write about your news
story one week but maybe three weeks
from now they're going to do a roundup
and you'll be in it so there are some
things where just the relationship and
just reaching out is good and can kind
of pay back later also politics
entertainment when that kind of news
happens sometimes there's an opportunity
to jump on and be included in some way
and also contextualizing other company
announcements so if Apple has big
developer news then maybe you're a
developer and have something to say or
contribute so reaching out and saying
hey here's what I think about it let me
know if you want to talk that can be a
way to get your company into the
conversation so here's an actual example
so simple habit was in wifey's last
batch and it's essentially Spotify for
meditation
she yuna the founder specifically wanted
to get it coverage and gadget and so she
found this reporter Nathan he wrote
several times about different streaming
apps and was specifically interested in
that like new kinds of content so he's
right about Spotify written about
YouTube TV and so she approached him she
had some seed funding to announce and
gadget doesn't actually write that much
about fundraising and she knew that so
she reached out shared the fundraising
news but also shared that they were to
be doing a new release it had a bunch
more content coming out in a few new
features and he was interested he asked
for more information she shared some
visuals and this is the story this is a
story um so that's a great example of
something that simple had it did so
relevant pitch to the right reporter
around news item here's another example
so this is a not not company milestone
base but actually customer based so like
we talked about showing your product
through the eyes of a customer this YC
company again some cable which lets
anybody build mobile apps without
knowing how to code they discovered this
customer they had in Yemen who again
without knowing how to code developed a
solar app or basically an app that they
brought thousands people solar power
that have lost power due to the civil
war in Yemen and it's a pretty cool
story right so they drafted up a pitch
they knew someone who knew the reporter
and the founder knew someone who knew
the reporter and drafted up in an email
for that person to then send to a
reporter at Fast Company so this is the
email asking if they can intro giving a
little bit of contest giving that really
short business description and the
reporter was interested this is the
story in Fast Company and here's an
example of writing the news waves we
talked about politics and entertainment
possibly being something to to jump on
it's not every day that this is an
opportunity so this is not your your
common example but we all might remember
last October there was some tapes that
were leaked of Donald Trump sing lewd
things on a bus and it was to put it
mildly
major news in the u.s. Hawley around the
world and so this happened that October
8th I think so deep Graham another YC
company they their product is basically
like search for speech
so they can search audio files like
Google searches images right and so they
saw an opportunity with all this talk
about are there more tapes is there
anything else to discover journalists
are going down that path of inquiry and
so they came in with what I would
consider kind of a light stun which is
hey we're making our products free for
journalists until Election Day
have at it search for whatever so they
got and so they were covered for that so
they were able to quickly think about it
they put up a blog post and they jumped
on it and this is a story they got in
TechCrunch so those are a few examples
and we talked you saw a few examples of
pitches and I would say that's your
number one tool you're very likely not
in a place for reporters are kind of
sitting on your site refreshing your
blog wondering what the next news is
going to be so you need to get to them
and so blog posts though is helpful to
link to just to give extra information
and don't attack what to not attach
stuff so it's a good kind of repository
for the full story too and to have that
if someone is interested they can click
through I get questions about press
releases they're not really for startups
that's the truth it's an older medium it
used to be gotcha used to be even more
intense than this but it's like I mean
it was like faxes coming into a newsroom
that was that you see the big utility of
a press release and then more recently
it was a good way to get in Google News
right you got you in search results the
Google has wised up about that a lot so
it doesn't really do that anymore
so your blog has just as much power to
get into those search results as the
press releases and partially press
releases if you're gonna put them over
the wire cost like the cost a couple
thousand dollars so it's not worth it
for a start-up really their tool for
public companies to make disclosures
about like market-moving news so that's
the main so it'll use it I guess the
only other exception would be if you are
in an industry that's kind of like an
older fashion industry like banking or
aviation
sometimes I go link to a press release
on your site can establish credibility
for partners not press but like partners
or other people that you might want to
get meetings with is you know for lack
of other press coverage so there's
and visuals and assets are really great
to include never as attachments because
the attachments are annoying we all know
that but just link to them from your
psyche either in your site or it's a
Dropbox link but because every story
will use a visual anyway a lot of
outlets want to create their own visual
for bigger feature stories but for like
a smaller news item they might just like
screenshot your website or find a
picture of the founder like speaking at
some event but maybe you don't like that
picture maybe is not flattering so I
always just say provide your own visuals
so hopefully they'll use one of those
and you'll be happy so I don't know why
I like shoved all this in one slide but
the other thing I want to talk about in
terms of official announcements are
exclusive versus embargoes which could
be its own slide about like how to
really really really really piss off a
reporter so listen closely because this
is important these are two tools that
are used in the PR world to brief a
reporter in advance of a news a date so
that they can have a full story ready to
go on the day of the news you can't use
them both together I'm going to talk
about them individually an exclusive is
I'm going to talk to you you one
reporter just me and you you're getting
the full story and that's it you're
getting that you're the only one I'm
talking about this until after you post
your story and then if someone calls me
I can talk to them but they're not going
to have the story ready to go it's yours
that's an exclusive it's as serious as
like a monogamous relationship if you
promise to give someone the story it's
theirs
got it okay an embargo is if you have
bigger news that you think multiple
reporters might cover which is common
especially for like a midsize startup
that has people who are kind of
following their news you can reach out
and say to each of the reporters I have
some news I'd like to preview on it the
news is going out on June 15th at 8 a.m.
Pacific would you like the news will you
agree to an embargo and they say yes
they're basically saying give me the
news if I write a story I will not
publish it until that specific time that
you told me so the trick here is use me
to make
you're being really clear in
communication with everyone because if
you send one reporter the wrong time
then they like post their story earlier
than Explorer reporters who had a story
that was already but they were
respecting your your ask so it's kind of
a little weird but these are things that
existed our tools and I would say
specifically for an exclusive it's
something that we use a lot for
early-stage startups because if you're
reaching out to reporter and you have
like that the customer story the once
impeccable that was actually offered as
an exclusive so that was just kind of an
extra carrot to say hey this is a cool
story and we'll give it to you just you
so the reporter the nose okay well I can
either take my time to actually talk to
the customer and I'm not like racing
against the clock to see because someone
else might write it before I do right so
it allows them to take their time take a
breath in and the right story they want
and also it's nice to not have to
compete for clicks on the story with
without our outlets so that's it's
that's why its uses it as a tool but
just make sure to respect it and use it
carefully so last of all listen and be a
source so it's one thing to reach out
when you have news but kind of on your
day to day you're really just following
the news and possibly taking
opportunities to be a source so there's
a couple things you guys know about
Google alerts and RSS feeds I one thing
you might not know about is this tool
called Harrow it's help a reporter out
and the website is help a reporter calm
and it's free you can subscribe to it
it's kind of a lot like you get three
mando emails every day and basically
what it is is reporters will they're
seeking a source for their story so
they'll actually submit a request for a
source so hey I'm looking for an expert
on molecular molecular biology deadline
is tomorrow at 5:00 p.m. Pacific and so
you see that you're an expert on
molecular biology so you can actually
reply and kind of let them know about
yourself and maybe they can use you as a
source so it's a good way sometimes you
can really strike it big and there's
something right on the money but it's
not I
no it's not a guaranteed road to to
coverage also some reporters will tweet
when they need a source will say hey I'm
looking for someone who's next roundness
so that's another way also most a lot of
reporters will tweet their own coverage
so again if you're if you're reading a
reporter's coverage and kind of
understanding what motivates them to
write or what types of stories are cool
for them Twitter is a great place to
hang out as well so a couple quick
examples of being a good source and I
always give I mean the one I always talk
about is Sam Altman having worked with
him he would like he just wanted to help
out and kind of because he was just
interested in this story and so this is
kind of the true test of a founder who
gets PR for me if someone who just
thinks story is cool someone who
actually wants reporters to have the
tools to put out a great story so he
would reach out even if something wasn't
within the realm of loop like if there
was a story about augmented reality or
something he would think someone and say
hey I'm really interested in I'm going
to reality if I know a lot about it and
then they would call him even though
there wasn't a specific loop tie-in that
was a way that he was there for them and
so when we did have news they at least
looked at the email you know so it
helped just kind of get that credibility
because they knew that he was interested
in them getting a good story to read
some examples from penny another YC
company in a recent batch and they this
New York Times example was penny saw
this comment that Jamie Dimon is the CEO
chase made about innovative think
startups not not holding a candle to the
offerings that Chase had for their own
customers and was kind of crapping on
innovative banking startups and it
wasn't widely covered like it was only
covered in a couple places they saw it
in Forbes and they notice the New York
Times hadn't covered it and there was a
specific reporter who they had been
continuing to read his coverage Ron at
the New York Times ran Lieber and they
felt like Ron would be interested in the
story yet he hadn't covered it so they
reached out to him said hey have you
seen this news what Jamie Dimon said
here's what we think about it we think
that innovative starts do have a place
and we have this perspective and I'm an
expert in this and so he was able to
jump on the phone with reporter give him
contact from what he thought and he was
in this story in
like the second paragraph and quoted
twice so this story that he wouldn't
have been in probably and if the
reporter had picked it up on his own
probably would have been in it but and
he wasn't it because he was able to kind
of die the reporter through it or at
least help him get to a place where he
wanted to write about it and the other
thing that penny worked on is they had
talked to a Bloomberg reporter about
chatbots because she had written a story
about that and they wanted to kind of
give her some some more experience I
guess I didn't really say what Penny's
good your personal finance up so it's
like a personal finance coach in your
pocket it's a bot um so they were
talking to her about thoughts and she
mentioned them there were two stories
she was working on one about like equity
grants and one about diversity hiring
and I was just kind of conversation that
they realized they had a friend who knew
a lot about equity grants they connected
her to the friend and I was just kind of
a nice gesture they did and then when
they were starting to look for their
first engineering hire these two male
founders with an app called penny and a
female bud wanted to hire a female
engineer to help to balance out their
company from the beginning they reached
out to her and said hey just
interestingly I know you were interested
in this we're actually doing this now so
anyway hope you having a good day
that's what we're doing so she got back
with them and said hey I want to profile
you through a whole hiring process so
she shouted them does this like in-depth
podcast on their hiring process so this
wasn't a story that they dreamt of in
Bloomberg probably a like a story about
their hiring process versus their
business but it was a great way to
develop this relationship with this
reporter the piece ended up turning out
really great they did end up making us
hire so this to me is just a good
example of a founder that gets gets a
good story and is like we'll invest in
just kind of making that happen so this
is kind of it I think from the other
tools that you have our um responding to
articles so if there's an article that
you might even have disagree with or
have a different point of view that's
another opportunity to reach out so it's
not always just news driven or trend
driven it could just be like hey you
wrote this I don't know if you ever
thought about it this way but anyway if
you ever want to explore this side let
me know I'm here
and then also you know the media is
changing the only like getting an
article rated value isn't only way for
someone to start seeing you as an
authority right so there are small
things you can do like commenting on
article not self-promotional not
plugging your business in any big way
but just as an interested person in this
topic
commenting on article on reddit Cora and
even creating your own content on your
blog or on medium these are good ways to
start just kind of dipping your toe in
establishing your credibility in the
field that you operate in so those are
some small things you can do and
[Music]
questions and actually as a surprise we
have Steven Levy here who is at
back-channel come on up Steven and
formerly at Wired and Newsweek way back
and he's described this is a journalist
even ask questions to you as well so you
can either ask me or the person who is
there any other line of questions yeah
and actually this is a super clue full
presentation I have to say right you
know and and you don't hear that from
all people in the a PR industry I think
that's true yeah so very good we have a
question right Becker I was just trying
to understand like the advantages of
like the exclusive first wanting to
exclusive so I imagine that being
non-exclusive potentially based more
presage make it Rison the case with like
comfortable and being comment about
people so there's like getting a better
story but like what are some of the
other advantages of doing exclusive
season movie yeah so the question is
what are the advantages of doing
exclusive versus an embargo because what
your understanding was is that if you do
an embargo you get more stories yeah
yeah sure yeah I'm dealing with this a
lot um you know for what I do you know I
much prefer exclusives and you know then
the publication that I found it in right
for called back channel as we do we
don't do a lot of stories we're not a
trade publication like TechCrunch so
we're not going to cover everything we
try to cover things that are special we
could tell things in depth so for us
it's important to have and
exclusive we don't want to write the
generic story that everyone else writes
there and the other problem with
embargoes is that in if it's a if what
you have first off what you have has to
be important to get a lot of reporters
and involved in therefore a non
exclusive story and what often happens
is that some pump someone gets wind of
it and then you know those little tweet
you know oh there's a company that does
X and you know there's 4 reporter
sitting there with the story and one of
them will have an editor it says that's
it the embargo is broken let's just go
with it so I would say well over half of
the embargoes I've ever been involved
with
get broken well and there's bad feelings
I would have said 25% I saw over here
flogging you know yeah yeah and and my
pet peeve is always bit of a big
publication like Businessweek where the
New York Times breaks an embargo
sometimes accidentally oh god we thought
it was like west coast lines and they
never suffer consequences yes but I
think I argue for the an important story
to tell and particularly as a complex
story
it can't be summed up neatly in a
sentence but what you have is really
cool on these xmx planation
then you really want an exclusive story
a reporter who's going to find it
worthwhile to spend a lot of time with
you and your company and tell out
definitive story you put it on the web
everyone gets to read it and for example
I did a story about this company called
viv which was a people who used to do
the Siri product there I did it for why
or does my explain my last story in the
public in the magazine until this week
actually there's a couple years ago and
they actually use that on their website
to explain themselves for a couple years
yes
yeah it's kind of and I think that's
that are the key point about exclusives
if someone can go deeper then as a
business that's kind of parts that's a
tool for you it's like a part of the
tapestry of your company it's it's kind
of the top of the search results it's
something that someone can actually take
and read and fall in love with your
company so even especially for
recruiting partnerships like that
stories in your email signature and you
know you know you can really cherish it
I think there's a question right behind
you Steven could you sort of like go
through some major different types of
publications
so there's TechCrunch there's New York
Times and sort of like mainstream
media's and then there's like the new
wave of media company is on medium
and then there's late but why there's
just all these different types can you
sort of go through like the pros and
cons to the different like sort of major
categories that you see yeah sure I
think I mean all ultimately you know
when you're going to do your pits you're
going to do what genre doesn't really
get yourself familiar with them but you
know the the larger distinctions is that
a publication like TechCrunch
you know considers itself almost
definitive to say anything important in
the industry we're going to do so
I know if YC still does this but when I
last did a dive in a batch they had
almost an informal relationship that any
the company's time came you know
TechCrunch would basically run their
verbal press release you know they they
have a call scheduled and you know
someone would read it out there I don't
know what there's so many companies yeah
there's so many more companies but it is
it's a hot target for a lot of ways yeah
yeah because they're going to do a lot
of stuff there and then and they're
interested in the business and yeah
other you know traditional publications
again they're not going to do as much
they're going to figure out it is a
significant in a business sense or a
technology sense in which case actually
you might have to consider a different
reporter for one of those publications
there you know if your company is an AI
company you're going to talk to the
person who covers AI as opposed to the
retail thing if you're you know commerce
company and a lot of the newer
publications Mike publications started
on medium we started actually a part as
part of medium again lots of different
kinds of stuff some some of them are
really focused on like what startup life
is like and then which case you might
have something unique to offer we do a
thing in my publication because a lot of
people in this community read us
cold war stories the if you know someone
has a really interesting story to tell
you know about what they do typically
actually as people who have already
established themselves and talked about
you know at a crucial part in the
formation of their company but you know
even so you know some of the younger
companies I've seen there you know how
stories interesting enough we did it we
did one with them in what's in store art
art is the art the art now I was
Christian who you know I was somehow
captivated with you know he was you know
this young guy from Detroit you know who
wound up being a sole founder who did a
few pivots and wound up to have these
people in Hong Kong you know create
paintings based on your photographs
remember that company you know yes
instigated something yeah and I and I I
followed him he was helpful thinking
against the source thing um you know he
was helpful to me you know talking about
his life as a startup when I did a story
about that batch and then you know later
I was connected with him and wound up
writing about his company come on yeah
that's great I think and I just the to
add on to the TechCrunch element to its
wind companies are in YC oftentimes
their goal after YC is to get investment
which is why TechCrunch it tends to be
their top target it's not every company
that has that as their top target but if
you think about that who is your
audience if your audience's investors
maybe the outlet is beverage about the
benefits of kind of reaching out your
borders versus creating generating your
own PR with like medium articles or
Twitter bases or other forms of social
media and you feel like you really need
to kind of reach out reporters to kind
of jittery to kind of politically based
right well the question is how you a
week answer reporters against things
that you can do yourself like writing
media articles and being active on
social media I'm sure you have an
opinion my opinion is pretty brief it's
that they're not mutually exclusive I
think that your story through your voice
is amazing and if you're able to start
developing content
on point for your customers and for
people who are who follow your company
that's amazing and that's helpful for
FeO so from a pure business standpoint
it's helpful but it's also really great
to create a dialog where you can
actually answer your customers problems
the other thing is helpful is to have a
third party validate your business by
thinking it's cool right and writing a
piece on it
yeah that's generally right but if
everything is out in the medium story
yes it's a little you know less you know
delicious for a reporter to do that I
did a story about a startup called
Banzai recently and interestingly that
came from you know a relationship I had
with a PR person who really knows my
work and you know can those okay you
know this is a guy who likes to do
things that really move the ball you
know and this is something different
there you know that I think is going to
meet Steven's needs and they had done
some stuff on medium and I look hard at
that to say boy do they give the story
away even though obviously if you have
you just put up stuff on medium you know
you're not necessarily it's not going to
be pretty rare to get a huge readership
from that you know so yes what I say
ultimately then it doesn't really matter
not many people read it but if you know
if you got what you wanted and yeah and
took off it might make a reporter think
twice to say gee that story's been told
already yes I think they might have
blown past the common sense point of too
big part of news is that it's new like
that someone hasn't talked about it yet
and that's that's a compelling point for
reporters
any other questions this week sort of
like crafting and scaffolding a story
that you directly give to reporters
versus sort of letting them do what they
want with it
be the one hand it must work for them
but on the other hand they sort of
exercise less creativity if you just
sort of give them that their distinct
copy and paste their article so the
question is I'm going to just even
answer it is what's the what's the
balance between doing a lot of pre-work
giving kind of like an outline to
reporter as these as you said
scaffolding versus just letting a
reporter run with it
well I mean you're going to need to you
know focus and in to explain what it is
but you know once the things get rolling
the reporter is going to want to take
his or her take on the thing there and
you know people reporters just don't
like being directed or saying oh this is
our story don't don't pay attention to
that uh you know so you know once you
open the door we're in so you know uh
yeah I hope what you want to say is
interesting enough to you know keep us
from what we find industry and I think
that I think pre-work is helpful at
least in like my my luck getting
responses from folks so you have to make
sure that they get that it's a cool
story so just saying this is my company
your thoughts is maybe not going to be
enough you need to talk to them about
the cool thing you're doing that they
might be interested in and it also
brings up another point that there are
no rewrites so the reporter gets to have
their time with your story and you don't
kind of get to review a draft or edit it
which I know seems common sense but it
is a question I get a lot another
question
thank you and thank you for parka
[Applause]